trump is the most admired man of 2020
according to gallup's annual poll
trump taking the top spot and ending the
12-year run of former president barack
obama
the current commander-in-chief beating
out others like president-elect joe
biden
dr fauci and the pope former first lady
michelle obama was named the most
admired woman topping vice
president-elect kamala harris and first
lady
melania trump so jason i'm going to
start with you on this
in all fairness if you look at the
numbers people who identified as
democrats
actually split their votes between
barack obama joe biden
anthony fauci donald trump got something
like 18
do you make anything of these year-end
polls i thought republicans hated polls
now
look with all due respect i i i admire
donald trump
uh i've got a lot of respect and
admiration for
for you know some of these people i
wouldn't put them on my top
ten are you kidding who are they asking
i mean i went and looked at the top 50
people on
instagram like the rock at 200
million christiana ronaldo 248 million
followers
who goes out and says oh yeah dr fauci
he's my man
are you kidding me who are they asking
they must be i don't get the list
because there's nobody on there that i
think i don't know
so this is just another fake poll
according to jason so lawrence who would
you name as
your most admired person this year i
don't know i mean i
i really don't put too much stock into
celebrities
um you know i just like they put on
their pants just like me and you marie
but i do think there's something to the
to donald trump becoming this
this figure you know i often said that
there are a lot of similarities
when it comes to the transform
transformative
uh guys that barack obama was
versus donald trump a guy that wanted
hope and change and really
galvanized the country around that
message and then you had donald trump
that was saying
you know that hope and change really
isn't working for you washington is not
fighting for you
that is my message i'm going to fight
for you and so i think we
if people would get out of their echo
chambers they would see
how there's a lot that although they had
different tactics
of getting things done there's a lot
that is similar to them as well
yeah emily it's interesting we've seen
this year you know sort of unsung heroes
like healthcare workers
postal workers people during this
pandemic that have really stepped up and
kept our country running
who would you have put at the top of
your list this year
oh uh oh gosh absolutely law enforcement
and the first responders a hundred
percent
and i think to to take lawrence's
comment and run it a few extra yards
there was also a poll that came out in
the preparation as we were doing for our
segment
that that went only to gop members and
it basically said look as the party's
reorganizing itself restructuring itself
should it be more like president trump
or should it be more like your average
gop congress member
and three out of four answered trump and
to me
the party needs to hear that message and
see exactly how the american people view
president trump that he put american
economic and military interests first a
recognition of the swamp
a refusal to operate in the swamp
prioritizing the average americans needs
for the party to succeed and to progress
through the post-trump era
the gop needs to take that as gospel
well see i think president trump stands
at the top
because he has been an incredible
president he has though marie he is
someone who led
one of the strongest economies we saw
pre-kovet this is a man who has gotten
more middle east peace deals done
in just one term alone he's gotten more
than half of the
all the peace deals we have seen in our
nation's history done
done in one term this is someone who got
mexico to step up to the plate on things
like illegal immigration this is someone
who's brought a business approach
to washington dc therefore solving
problems
when people like joe biden who have been
there forever created the mess that
president trump went to go
fix and i also think it's remarkable
because you have a media
who has vilified him demonized him lied
about him and yet he still sits atop
the throne and marie i love you but this
must be a hard segment to leave
no no i mean if you took a poll of the
least admired american i think donald
trump would probably be at the top of
that one historic
um popularity numbers so
number one number one we'll see if next
year
we will see us next year when he's no
longer president if he's even anywhere
in the top ten we will see